لقد وعد سياسيو [الموسيقى] الأجانب بأنهم
مسجلين إذا تمكنوا من السيطرة على
الكونغرس ، فسوف يقضون العامين
المقبلين في
التحقيق مع
الرئيس بايدن وخصومهم السياسيين ،
وهذا كل ما يريدون فعله
، ويرون أنه رد ،
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
قلت  في الوقت الذي يكون فيه لدينا
رئيس ديمقراطي وبيت جمهوري ،
يمكنك أن تتوقع
إجراءات عزل ليست هذه هي الطريقة التي يُفترض
أن تنجح فيها إجراءات الإقالة
ولكني أعتقد أن الديمقراطيين تجاوزوا
هذا الخط وأعتقد أنه سيكون هناك ضغط هائل
على منزل جمهوري للبدء
إجراءات العزل
[موسيقى]
سنفوز وسنواصل الفوز
على كل مستوى وهذا ما
كنا هنا ولكني أردت فقط أن أعطي ذلك
كإيجاز صغير عندما
تفكر في إعداد الجدول غير العادل
عندما تفكر في كيفية
لقد عوملنا بشكل غير عادل ،
لقد عوملنا كمجموعة ، إنه أمر
فظيع وعلينا إعادة بلدنا